hey it's your boy boosie you already
know check me out on the bootleg kev
show asap we turning up
yo bullet cat podcast bootleg kev show
got my guy in here man
boosie what's up bro what's up bro
welcome welcome
so you in la um you just told me you
just got in wrapping up a movie and
you're getting business together for a
second movie
right right right right i'm uh i mean
i'm in talks right now to
do business with my my first film i
directed
my struggle and uh i'm almost finished
shooting my comedy
me desert banks grove he wrote flavor
flav listen you in a comedy is overdue
bro
it's overdue yeah i'm trying to see like
i want to see you do like a sitcom
though you know what i'm saying like
boozy's house like what you're like
not the reality show cause i know you
did that i mean like a sitcom like
like like a sick call yeah like on some
like because i on on on this film
i'm like four different characters i
went eddie murphy
oh you eddie murphy you [ __ ] nutty
professor yeah i went i went four
different characters so i'm
i'm trying it out you know did you have
to wear a fat suit or any like no i
ain't put on a fast suit i was uh
i was a junkie i was a muslim
a nerd so was it uh hard for you to be
uh a junkie nah nah like i've known so
many so my life
i know how they talk i know how they
look i know they walk
so that's probably my best uh that's
your best acting job was the junkie yeah
yeah uh crackhead arrested i think
crackhead rusty was one of my favorite
yeah crackheads have a certain level of
endurance and uh
persistence in life that i you have to
admire like imagine if
most people in this world were dedicated
to whatever they wanted to do in life as
much as crackheads are dedicated to
getting more crack
right right everybody would be paid
everybody would be happy you know what
i'm saying like imagine like you know
the way you're getting after it getting
your bags getting your music popping
imagine if everyone had that same drive
people who smoke crack are the most
dedicated human beings alive i respect
the [ __ ] out of it man yeah
i got a lot of crackhead friends you
know like who i came up with
older people i tend to follow
like i've attended you know antenna
file phone man do you have a do you know
anyone who is uh
functional crackheads like they smoke
you know crack
like they smoke crack but they still got
their nine to five and they still you
know yeah yeah not really a nine to five
but they still insane like they got a
house
yeah yeah they got their family they
just happen to smoke crap
oh they don't have their family but they
pretty stable like you wouldn't like
like they they smoke it and they don't
act like they smoke
yeah because you know they're controlled
okay okay okay yeah cause i mean i've
been watching that snowfall
you watch snowfall yeah yeah yeah and so
far is a bad [ __ ]
hey when franklin saints girlfriend the
pretty girl with the cop father
yeah but she hit the crack pipe yeah and
she just automatically was turned the
[ __ ] out
yeah like if you came up in a cragger
area like when i came up either your
mother or father was on crack
it's no way your mother or your father
was one one was on crack
you know it's just it's just how it was
you know like young people were smoking
it
what's the craziest drug you've ever
tried boozy i was addicted to pcp
wow i was addicted to pcp uh
i was i was gone out there with it man i
would so would you just dip the
cigarettes in or would it be yeah i
dipped the cigarettes in uh sometimes i
get a fall that's already dipped too but
uh
my first time smoking was with bushwick
bill
doing pcp the first time you ever did
pcp was with bushwick but like it was
like the second time
second time yeah and you were and you
were you were a teenager yeah
i was like doing pcp with bushwick bill
yeah give me the story behind this
uh we had we had a group we had a group
ride our hood that was making moves uh
full down entertainment
and everybody come [ __ ] when they big
dogs everybody come in this city and
[ __ ] with them and they like bush we'll
be
bush we deal in the hood right so we
went over there on arizona street and
they you know they smoking wit
so you know i got in a circle you know
what i'm saying that [ __ ] was crazy but
that's that was the most cause i used to
hallucinate so much well no it's crazy
because like i've done shrooms and [ __ ]
yeah and that should i have you tripping
a little bit but i heard pcp is like a
whole nother level of like
that's pretty wild [ __ ] like yeah it's
especially when you total guns
give me like a describe what is that
likes hitting like for people because
pcp i feel like is something that is not
kind of
widely used nowadays like we don't hear
about like back in the 90s you know
we would hear metaman yeah we would hear
mataman and wu-tang talking about
smoking on sherman [ __ ] but like
nowadays is not a thing what is that
like to it's like what's that high like
man
uh it's a pear no i have but a
but uh but a strong have
you feel you feel dominant
you know i'm saying you feel paranoid
too
so uh one time like i
i got off it because my mom was gonna
put me in a crazy house she was gonna
then she was acting like she was
tripping time i going to the pcp man to
my she gonna play the police on him
if he sell me [ __ ] so that's how i got
off this [ __ ] my mama was tripping and
saying she's gonna put me in a crazy
house well you gotta get that episode
yeah i came home my feet was bleeding i
was crying i said
horses and demons was behind me it's a
real story like i
i had caught a flat on the um on the
river road and i had to walk like four
miles home in the dark
and uh while you were high yeah it had
to be a crazy walk
yeah horses and demons got behind me on
my walk and i ran home
i was bleeding my mama to cry that's
crazy so that was that your worst
experience on that show
i think about like um the first friday
when smokey hits
the pcp yeah and he ends up in the
chicken coop
yo um what what what obviously you know
you've had a i feel like you've always
been one of the most entertaining
entertaining people period uh
but i feel like the pandemic really kind
of
showed the world how amazing and funny
you've been this whole time right like
you know like your ig lives were just
[ __ ]
right right just been on live like no i
know i know but
but now people are on their phone at
home and they had to sit down and really
get on it you know
you know i'm saying like put your [ __ ]
on live i'll give you a hundred dollars
whatever
that [ __ ] is like that [ __ ] is like
culture at this point yeah that [ __ ] get
on my nerves
you know i was just going out chilling
them off because [ __ ] asking me
for money on live so i just
said that [ __ ] that [ __ ] went crazy but
i ain't getting a [ __ ]
nothing i ain't getting a [ __ ] no
thought knives for no [ __ ]
that's fair i was just you know i was
just
i was just going off at the time and i
mean we was all at home going crazy
yeah and that's out of control you know
[ __ ] be all in the airport all in the
mall man my sister
i put up [ __ ] lips right now live for a
thousand dollars i'll be like nah
bro like that [ __ ] i was just going off
at the minute well you have a guy
offer up their sister all the time every
every other day
man my sister won't put up [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen live right now bro
you can cash out you can cash out me
right now you cash at me you can see my
sister's [ __ ] right now
what about anybody ever like come at you
like yo my wife my girl
she down nah i ain't nothing i ain't no
[ __ ] with the uh they ain't nobody come
with a wife but you know like
that's surprising yeah there's some
weird dudes out here bro they trying to
get that dog now
um but you man you've been having like
this
i feel like your instagram page keeps
getting banned bro yeah
um which which is terrible because
i know how how big a big part of your
business that is you know what i mean
whether it's promoting
other people's businesses you know all
that like where where's your ig standing
like
has there been any sort of communication
about getting the og one back
with with facebook with with with the
zuck hey brown that was up mad man
stuck mad at me i hadn't tried everybody
in the world to get my instagram back
but you can't stop me i'm you stop that
[ __ ] there might make one tomorrow
another name you got to shut the site
down
that's fair you don't have this [ __ ]
just i'm gonna get money on that
[ __ ] regardless i don't give her
through a third party
i have somebody else post me but you
can't stop me man i'm gonna
i'ma ride that [ __ ] and i'm
trying to work on my own [ __ ] too i got
i got genius geniuses working on apps
and things like that because i need to
be uncensored man
yeah i mean twitter's the most
uncensored place if you're yeah i love
twitter now i've been on twitter the
last two weeks
you're going to twitter posted girls
eating [ __ ] at my outdoor party for
sure yeah like and then nothing happens
nothing you could get retweets might if
you go to if you were to log on to my
twitter
you would judge me because it's all just
smut bro i'm just following just nothing
but
porn [ __ ] and yeah only fans i said i
tweeted
i say man they sucking dick on twitter
they are sucking dick on twitter like
for real bro like
there's hoes eating ass on twitter shout
out to tiana trump you know what i'm
saying
uh yeah no twitter's i think twitter is
your platform and then you did you got
are you still doing the only fans thing
yeah i'm doing all the fans thing how
does that work because you're not like
actually
on the i'm like the hugh hefner so
you're like hosting the [ __ ]
yeah i'm in the house so it's like kind
of like what was going on on your ig
live but
but much better right but much better
you you know you seeing
you know everything you know my boosted
bag is they ought to change
what is the wildest [ __ ] because you
know i remember when you had the party
with trouble
in atlanta and there was the infamous
cucumber party which seemed to have
kicked off a trend of a lot of women
sucking in [ __ ] cucumbers across this
entire country
but that that was the first time i had
saw it but what is the craziest [ __ ]
booze that you have ever seen a female
do with your own eyes when it comes to
just the nasty [ __ ] because i feel like
you've probably seen it all
i don't really know is change turned on
it's just normalized now just go down
and suck a dick while we were right
there in vip
it's just how i go down you know we're
gonna cover him up we're gonna give him
block of michelle
you know they know they know like we we
with that [ __ ] like we're having a good
time
so just a girl sucking dick in vip in
the middle of the club that's just kind
of
that's pretty dick jacked off a lot too
so you get a hand job yeah we get hand
jobs all in the club
i might lay behind my [ __ ] yeah beat
this [ __ ] right quick
he go cover it hey so let me ask you
something is it hard for you to like
finish in a club
nah you just gotta use it really you
gotta focus bro you gotta like cause i
feel like if i'm in the club and there's
all these the homies all right i'm gonna
get hit
i'm gonna get here in the club that'd be
gonna be already damn it up
okay okay cause i feel like it would be
hard for me to get all the way
to that point if i got out like you know
i don't know a rookie with doing it in
the club
fair enough that's why you're gonna be
he said i've been i've been getting it
in the club for a minute not really just
you know just a little head sometimes
you're gonna get a
you know celebrities get off your head
like you know you get offered head a lot
what is the quote like like what is like
the
for you you know if you get off your
head a lot that means you turn down a
lot ahead right yeah
so what would make you want to turn down
the head if it's is the girl not pretty
is she
her teeth her teeth um
[Music]
her shoes i look at their shoes their
feet
things like that i look at their mouth
their feet just make sure they look like
they're taking care of gotta be depends
on what mood i mean also
so what what shoes are a no-go like if a
[ __ ] has these shoes on
like what if a [ __ ] got timberlands on
uh timberland's not that bad not that
bad all right especially if you're in
new york
yeah especially if you're in new york
you might you might be sexy with them
okay yeah but uh you can't have no dirty
ass voices on
some dirty forces what about some black
forces
can't have no [ __ ] um the wrong
jaw and john he
came out of mexican jargon the team to
team jordan
team [ __ ] you ain't hitting this
[ __ ]
yo that's so funny because we all be
about hobies are always we got we got a
friend we had some teams
[ __ ] can't fly around you got to have
the retros where the team jordan hey you
know
me and freddie gibbs were in texas and
uh we had a homie named brian moses
who's a real
real big comedian and he had the most
busted down team jordans on the entire
trip
and he's he was he swear he was rocking
them [ __ ] though you know what
i'm saying they're like bro
those are the mexican jays for sure them
team jordans ain't it
so a [ __ ] pulls up with some team j's
some dirty forces
i'm smoking cigarettes or smoking
cigarettes
i don't want you to suck i don't want my
dick smelling like nuts
that's fair man that's fair what is uh
you know
i just had we just had young blue up
here um and
you know obviously i've spoke to him a
few times and he's always speaking very
highly of you and obviously you know
you're the guy who found him um i feel
like you don't get enough
kind of uh accolades or respect in the
game when it comes to just being a ceo
man
like what's going on with uh with the
label and and and some of the other
artists that you're working with man
we're just working we're just trying to
build it about that you know
the two that up next you know my son he
up next
we got a lot of artists we got
you know blue already took off so yeah
blue's going crazy he's like
such a nice dude man like smart as hell
ain't with no [ __ ] like seems like
he's just you know destined for for
right superstar my heart is ain't got to
be with the [ __ ] right i'm with the
[ __ ]
i'm gonna go out there [ __ ] my artist
that's what you feel like
that's what you build a team around all
this [ __ ] have to
be gangsta um i
i love the way you posted on your on
your uh social media
you had your kids walk in your property
line yeah as a punishment
gun line okay okay so yeah because i
guess your mom was coming over and was
complaining about how bad the kids were
i'm sick of them
they they they don't know how to
they just they just get out of hand you
know they just get out of hand
we got to a point where he had three
four people coming in my house like
you know my engineer my security like
man we can't sleep every night but they
throwing water on us but i can't sleep
bro you know like i'm gone bro like
you know so your kids are just wilding
just just turning up yeah just just out
of control bro
just get tired of it sometimes how many
kids you got eight
i mean [ __ ] man that's a team bro i
should start in five and
that's a whole rotation in the finals
and only two of them live with me so
when all of them come like you know
they get rowdy get round and i'll be
able to put my foot down and
that's one way i put my foot down i
don't get tired of whooping bro
i don't want to whoop them all the time
you know so
i make them walk that fence for four or
five hours and take their phone
so like yo y'all go out there when they
come in and sweat going down both sides
their eyes yeah
did you get any flack for like uh for
posting that my mama
your mom was not yeah that's why i had
him pull him back in she called once
you know get my [ __ ] grandchildren
from off that gate
with these you should put me on the gate
man
let me tell you something that's the
most annoying [ __ ] cause i got two kids
and whenever they're grabbing like never
the grandparents and you're like bro you
trying to stop
let me parent my nah they won't spoil
them it's like you do all this work with
your kids
and then the grandparents will come over
for the weekend and [ __ ] it all up and
let them do whatever they want let them
eat whatever they want give them what
they want
that's how it goes down bro i mean
that's really why they're grandparents i
guess
it's crazy because your your children
have had viral moments of their own like
right before
you got out of jail when your daughter
had that famous yeah
i told y'all [ __ ] oh my god i was
living in tampa at the time
and i just remember like that video
coming out
i think was the first show you did out
of jail was it in orlando
or was that like the second show was
like the second thing i just remember
man florida was on fire for you boozy
when you
when you first got out bro i i never
seen no energy like that any
at any time bro living in the south when
you were fresh out bro it was it was it
was it was crazy
um but yeah but like how's your daughter
doing the daughter that was in that
video did she like does she realize how
like famous she was for that for that
point in time because that video was
[ __ ] everywhere i'm kind of having
trouble with her right now
so cuz she's older now right how old is
she she like 14
13 14. so
she's been fighting this [ __ ] all on
instagram i miss my baby
i ain't saying that i will mama right
now but i miss my baby
is it hard to to deal with because i'm
how many baby mamas you have
hold on
six five or six five or six
you're not sure that's great
i got three for one girl in the wrist i
got one
that sounds like that sounds like uh
five then three for one
or maybe six i don't know chris my math
is not good three for one girl
so it's three so you might have six six
six uh is it hard to deal with like
all of the baby mamas oh it used to be
like you know
it used to be but i'm not only having
trouble with one baby mama right now
like i'm i've been having this sweet boy
i ain't gonna lie to having this sweet
because i ain't [ __ ] nothing right
you [ __ ] your baby moms that's when you
have all the [ __ ] problems and [ __ ]
yeah cause then they get emotional then
they say
[ __ ] when they when they shouldn't have
to say [ __ ] so
i just i just keep it cultural i'm in a
good position with my baby mamas i ain't
gonna lie bro
i'm kind of wanting another baby right
now you know what i'm saying about go
for number nine
yo my little girl five my baby girl so
is there anything in particular you're
looking for in a baby mama or is it i
think i'm going to china and get a
chinese uh
a and she gonna sign it over to me i'm
gonna be the mother and the father
so you're gonna go to china yeah i wanna
i want a chinese little boy
he's not gonna be me yagi hatch
sick ass booster fade comb go straight
through that [ __ ]
wait wait hold on miagi give me
you've been thinking about this yeah man
my law you're going over there and get
the egg
the yagi hatch yeah so you're gonna go
over there and you're gonna
i'm gonna pay for the head so he's gonna
sign it over to me
so you're gonna artificially inseminate
a woman
or are you gonna i'm trying to figure
out how this how this works man
i'm gonna put my sperm in the cup also
okay so you're not even gonna [ __ ] this
girl you're just gonna like yo
give it to the scientists and let them
handle what they got to handle yeah
they're gonna put our stuff together
and then you got miyagi hatch what's
that name bro what is that
um it come from mr miyagi you know what
i'm saying okay okay
i was a karate kid fan you [ __ ] with uh
cobra kai
who that is the new the new karate kid
show on netflix oh no i ain't on that
show oh you got to get on that
i ain't no [ __ ] it's like bo it's it's
the original characters
but like 30 years later so
the one dude who the karate kid beats
reopens cobra kai the dojo
and then they have a rivalry with their
kids it's wild bro
i gotta check it out if you're a karate
kid fan you gotta watch cobra kai bro
i gotta check it out so miyagi hatch
will be child number nine
you're just gonna cash out the egg and
have a a lovely
blasian baby right with the boozy fade
right you've put a lot of thought into
this man right
yeah i'm not going to be the first one
not to have a baby mother
are you just a life hack yeah i'm not
going to i'm not going to have a baby
mother
celebrate me on mother's and father's
day here's the contract i need your egg
i need your egg you signed everything
over to me here's the funds
you're out it's like you're out the life
you'll never meet this kid
you'll never see this kid in your life
you're going to be in china i'm going to
be
over here in the usa yeah damn
you might you might uh for anybody who
who's you know because baby mama drama
serious
yeah man i could do this by myself and
then obviously
there's a couple names child support is
a [ __ ] too like how much a month
do you have to like
pay out child support i i'm at a good
i'm at a good spot
you know i'm paying my baby all my baby
mama's like a couple grand
that's not bad that's not bad at all you
know there's a lot of people i mean
but i'm doing way more than that for my
for your kids it's like it's not like
they're not
at your crib and you're not taking care
right right right right right
but even when they not with me they they
get that
like they can be with me for eight seven
months they mama still gonna get they
they money regardless man i hope i hope
that you pull off this china play
because this would be amazing it's going
to be legendary
legendary going down is my legend one of
my most legendary moments
have you already had like any
discussions with uh anybody i've been in
talks with my attorney and everything he
talks with the people over there and
everything we just
it's just a process we're getting it
together hey man
it's lit um i saw you and webby were
back together recently
yeah uh which obviously all your day one
fans
have been waiting for that moment um
you know he's he's an interesting guy
you're an interesting guy
you guys uh is there gonna be any any
any more music being made between y'all
or something or is it just a moment i
think so the moment too sweet
and the bags would be too big if y'all
do that tour yeah man
you guys haven't gotten 75 80 000 right
now
you know that's crazy you just you right
yeah no man we i got we got we got an
eight and five thousand licked the other
day so
so you guys are getting sixty by myself
but you guys are actively doing stuff
together right now
as far as like bookings right right we
didn't did we did three shows together
but we gotta we gotta get in the studio
and come up with a project and that'll
solidify the tool yo it's crazy to think
like
so much of what's going on in hip-hop
right now can really be traced back to
you influence-wise
all right people don't give me my listen
let me tell you something when i hear
what's going on in jacksonville
when i hear what's going on in your
hometown
alabama i i hear so much of like this
all is
from boozy sonically a lot of this [ __ ]
is
you started this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying as far i mean like wayne gets a
lot of credit and chief keith gets a lot
of credit but i'm like bro like
this [ __ ] she made this gangster rap
[ __ ] believable the pain
[ __ ] talked about it and all that [ __ ]
but i made this [ __ ] believable
you know what i think you did too like
[ __ ] don't give me that credit but i
made gangsta rap
this [ __ ] believable like like [ __ ] my
[ __ ] went with every story
like [ __ ] i made these [ __ ] won't rap
about you know like
but i think you did a great job of like
actually introducing real pain into your
music like you know what i'm saying like
when he would hear
certain like album cuts from you you'd
be like oh this [ __ ] you feel that that
[ __ ] hits different you know what i'm
saying right and it's the same pain in
the music
here now it's just people inflicted a
little bit but i was really the first
one talking about
i wouldn't say the first one but i was
one of the ones who
who made you feel like i grew up with
you
like i was in the house with you like
you know i i i put [ __ ] in tears i
raised florida i raised all these states
you know uh on gangster music
i raised a lot of i raised a lot of
states bro and uh
you just you feel like you get the
credit you deserve though i i i i feel
like
i i get the realness i deserve i don't
get the credit i deserve i get the
realness and i'm happy with that you
know
most people come up to me and say they
don't you're a real [ __ ]
you know instead of [ __ ] you're a fool
just rap [ __ ] your food this
you know most people give me strikes on
being a real [ __ ]
have you obviously you know uh you got
shot last year
yeah um good to see you walking around
all right yeah
um and then there was like another
incident too right where
there were some shots that were close by
right oh yeah that was at a video shoot
at the video shoot yeah that wasn't my
smoke though but i'm saying like
obviously
you know i'm tired bullets ain't got no
names like nips
ain't got no name i'm tired in it for
life so mike my question is like
does that like make you kind of re
reconsider kind of how you
you you move around or uh yeah you know
like uh
i move around how i'm moving around you
know what i'm saying like
every time they tried to get me i ain't
get got but you know i would i'll be
ready bro like
you know life life i chose put me in
these situations
you know i chose this life so this put
me in these situations so
every day i gotta you know i gotta i
gotta be watching on my real view and
that's
that's part of my life were you worried
uh like that you might not walk the same
again
because i know that i saw like uh oh you
had the cane and [ __ ] and
uh i kind of knew i was gonna shake back
i wouldn't you know
i don't really listen to dogs and you
really can't be that's why my leg ain't
all the way here
now because i because you didn't listen
[ __ ] doctors right
was you still [ __ ] with the bum leg
yeah
yeah i just ain't let them ride me but i
was [ __ ] from the back
i ain't let them get on me and ride my
leg down to the
bed but i was i put my leg in my other
hand
with your leg all cast it up
but i couldn't let him get on top of me
oh that's great man oh
man what is um you know outside of doing
the movie thing
first of all what's the name of your
first uh this this movie my struggle my
struggle my struggle that's not the
comedy that's not the comedy
that's that's that's my life story so
your life story
and you're playing yourself i got three
people i got my son playing me
at first then i got junkie jit playing
me
then i played me at the when i get grown
that's fire so you got your son in the
movie
yeah one of the best movies in america
how are you gonna put it out are we to
get it on netflix that's what i'm doing
right now i got a meeting with netflix
tomorrow i got a couple more meetings so
i don't know how i'm going to put it out
yet i'm shopping and now it's done
what are your top five favorite movies
of all time i'm curious
we're probably around the same age so
coming to america okay
uh
blank check okay uh
blank check was fire uh hold on wasn't
tone logan blank check
uh
[Music]
what's the movie with uh matthew
cunningham matthew mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey when he played the lawyer
oh with samuel j oh uh the about the kkk
yes uh [ __ ] i saw when i was a kid
that was the first time i ever saw the
kkk on tv i was like these [ __ ]
is evil
no bruh i forgot it he plays the lawyer
and he plays the lawyer samuel jackson
goes to the court smoking
that's a hell of a movie that's three of
them uh two more
two more
have to go back uh
goonies goonies is fire
i watch going is over and over um
the last one [ __ ]
ghost ghost shout out to patrick swayze
patrick swayze dinner more i'm not gonna
lie you're five
or very they're all i mean i'm a movie
they're a movie head these are all great
movies i got a thousand movies in mind
that's how that's what helps me direct
everybody who watches movies like that
you can directly i remember watching
blank check as a kid
and and i thought like tone loke was
like like actually like a really great
rapper because he had wild things and
[ __ ] and he was in the movie and then
once i really started to get into
hip-hop i was like oh nah he what that
wasn't it yeah
blank check um what outside of uh the
movie [ __ ] and obviously you know
we're always looking for new music from
boosie so what is what is going on with
your [ __ ] your catalog
uh my catalog i'm dropping the go talk
three friday
i'm dropping it back to br cd august
28th the day booster badge i'm dropping
that
all i'll be our producers all br artists
uh i'm dropping another one a monday
after that called mississippi
uh i'm dedicated to mississippi and i'm
dropping
another album i don't know when i'm
gonna drop this but it's called july 6
cause
july 6 i did like 14 songs in one
session
oh [ __ ] so i'ma just drop that july 6th
14th song in one session
yeah and i woke up at two o'clock how
long was the session like uh 24 hours
i woke up at two o'clock and i went in
at three o'clock
i woke up at two o'clock in the day and
i went in at three o'clock in the
morning stayed all night
and i took a bath in between that time i
mean you got to
yeah you got to right um
i know we talked about uh you know
obviously you you and fredo are related
uh and he said he ran into you i think
in the airport or something yeah
you guys ever ever link up and maybe do
a record i know that there might be some
politics behind that that might yeah
it's a lot it's a lot of [ __ ] that you
know
like people can't that we can't talk
about all right right right
you know that that i stand on you know
what i'm saying
there ain't nothing he didn't did it's
just you know people some people
affiliated with him so
it ain't you know i just i just stay
away from a lot of [ __ ] bro
yeah i mean i feel like a lot like a lot
of artists who are
bad yeah no no the baton rouge [ __ ] is
crazy i still
stay baton rouge and jacksonville got
the wildest politics right now
it's [ __ ] crazy bro but now speaking
of like baton rouge in general like i
feel like you've always kind of
since you've been out like i feel like
you've been a big homie to a lot of
people as far as just like collaborating
with them
sharing your fan base with them and it
seems like
a lot of these artists who you've been
cool with they they're not they don't
learn from your mistakes
because you've made a lot of mistakes
that i think like i feel like you've
made a lot of mistakes for
a whole generation of rappers to see
like hey look this is what happens when
this this and this
game bro that's all you could do you
know i just gave them games bro that's
what i yeah i'm game you know
you gotta learn from yourself that's
what anybody you gotta learn from your
own mistake
i was gay game you know people gave me
game but i was still
ignorant towards how i wanted to feel
and how i wanted to live so
i just give them game i get all the
youngster game you know especially if i
see a little bit of them and me
i give them game cause i want them to go
through what i went through you know so
yeah i mean i think like uh the biggest
artist out of your city
since you is obviously young boy you
know what i'm saying
yeah he's that i mean on youtube i mean
with the kids don't say my city
no i'm saying but out of the biggest
dude to come out is i mean no in the
world for sure
this dude's been running youtube for
like five straight years but like what's
your relationship like with young boy at
this point in time you know that's my
people you know what i'm saying uh
that's my people you know he going
through this situation now but he gonna
he gonna be back he's gonna be back
stronger than ever
[Music]
he's gonna be back stronger than ever
he's just you know everybody you gotta
sit down sometime
very similar like in as far as just like
come ups with you like obviously he's
right i see a lot of him and me you know
i see a lot of him and me you know going
through all the stuff he went through in
the
in the city you know all the baby mamas
and
you guys have a lot of similarities and
obviously he's locked up when he gets
out he's that that comeback yeah it's
gonna be crazy yeah
yeah yeah i just i i wrote him i wrote
him the other day you don't say have you
talked you talked to him since he's been
locked up yeah
i wrote them i i talked to him for a
couple minutes but i wrote them and
i wrote them and gave him some positive
words you know what i'm saying and uh
just told him you know i'm saying now
you're gonna get graded later how
important is that like being in jail
like knowing like like having people
check in because i don't think a lot of
people realize like how lonely man a
letter make you man a little make your
whole
money bro you know from somebody or just
a talk on the phone
cause i remember i think i think you and
i talked to you and you had said that
like jeezy had constantly checked in
with you and you were yeah when you were
incarcerated yeah that meant that
that meant a lot to me anybody who who
reached out to me
they meant a lot to me because you know
you'd be feeling like you lost in there
sometime when
you don't hear from somebody who
contacted you every day for a year
um you'd be feeling like you know [ __ ]
you couldn't find a way to contact me or
contact my people
right so that's what i do even if i
don't hear hear from nobody
i'm gonna reach out to reach out reach
out my hand
it's crazy because um you know and
that's the same thing with anybody
i if i ride with you and you go to jail
that's how i feel i'm obligated you know
what i'm saying
you've been on you've been on the other
side you know [ __ ] with money who
i [ __ ] with i used to be like damn [ __ ]
you ain't gave my mama you ain't getting
nobody nothing
right right right you know i know how i
feel sometimes like damn
it's almost like you go you just posted
250 [ __ ] you can't give me
put 1500 on my books you know what i'm
saying you want to you don't know that
to you on the outside looking in
that's why you ain't nobody got to
contact me
i'm going to show up that's a beautiful
thing how um how you know obviously
you and moe 3 had a great relationship
dropped a joint album he passed away in
a you know tragic incident
um how how you know i felt like he was
on his way
to being massive um he was one of the
most talented
in the industry no he's a beast um how
how
how how much did that hurt man you know
what i'm saying not to say that you
don't lose people a lot or that you
haven't lost a lot of people but you
know obviously
you guys had an album together and i
felt like he was kind of on the on the
brink of becoming something special in
the industry
that kind of that broke my back though
you know
lowe's my boy you know like we laugh
together you know you don't really laugh
with too many rappers
i spend time with too many rappers y'all
just see each other
but uh we got money together me and mo
you know my mother was my boy bro you
know mo my boy
he missed out here bro now people are
saying how great
man he is die you don't get your flowers
to you
that's especially somebody who's like i
feel like you've been underrated you
know what i mean
when someone like that passes it's like
finally people kind of pay attention
because they see his name in the
headlines
no i just mean i just mean like
nationwide yeah let's see what's that
dude
you go to a show and he they know every
song
wonderful shout out to him and rest in
peace
um what else was i about to ask you
about boozy
what about the weed game man are we
gonna get some boozy og are you going
i got somebody out here trying i don't
[ __ ] with og no man
that [ __ ] play it out what are you
smoking right now i'm smoking
exotic i'm smoking [ __ ] made for animals
this [ __ ] i'm smoking no like scarface
with snot and cocaine
yes on the movement yes that's how i'm
smoking weed
you're not snorting the weed right no
i'm not snorting the weeds i was about
to say you'd be the first rapper to ever
do that no
what you calling that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
hitting the weed right now i'm gonna
post him now
bishop don juan you song no i'm gonna
post him on my instagram when we leave
what was he doing see him i'm gonna be
the first one he smokes his blunts out
his nose bro
oh bro pull it up bro have you tried it
hell no hell no
man i saw too many people snorting
cocaine when i was little let me ask you
this
have you ever done the edible thing yeah
i've done the edible thing but i don't
like the other one
i like the dab because you'll be gonna
die
you'll [ __ ] die
did you have like a bad edible
experience because you eat too much
edibles
you just gotta wait that [ __ ] out it
ain't like you could eat it it gets in
your bloodstream so
i had a bad damage what happened
like my my heart was being too fast bro
like
nah it's [ __ ] up like i had a bad
experience bro like coming home
from prison and thinking i'm
thinking i know what i'm doing going
there and hit a [ __ ] dab in
their mouth
and it's kind of crack head-ish because
there's the the torch
yeah it's not like you know what i mean
like you felt like i was hitting the
fight
yeah i'm saying like oh let's see he's
hitting it out the nose
oh no that's crazy bro and he's doing it
like like he's been doing this
like bro he viral i'm sending him
is that is that magic don juan yeah
that's that's the bishop man
oh man that's the [ __ ] that's some old
she has some seventy [ __ ]
oh that's wild i'm 70 60 [ __ ]
cheers dolomite [ __ ] man yeah now the
edibles is the mother but the dab [ __ ]
is crazy
the first time i ever hit a dab and i
saw the thing with the the torch and
i said this [ __ ] feels like crack
headish to me
and then you hit it and then your
[ __ ] face is melted off
and then you have like the worst night
of your life which is what happened to
me shout out to action bronson he took
advantage of me and had me do three hits
back to back to back and then i had to
interview him and it was
it was it was horrible um yo one of the
the dope things that you did recently
was this mike tyson interview
which was like last year because that
was kind of like when you were in la
doing the
run with mo three but they held on to it
for a while three albums
yeah so they they held onto that for a
minute cause i remember hearing about it
and uh and i was like yeah when's this
[ __ ] gonna come out but that was an
interesting uh interview
how did you take mike's intensity
because it was
very i mean it was it was up there
uh i ain't gonna take it like nothing
bro like
i was just i was just you know i was
just
i was just in there you know and we had
a lot of stuff we talked about off
camera like bro
the character he's a wild boy dude
yeah i mean i thought i thought that was
like
because you're you're you're a
personality he's a personality yeah
i was really running i was asking him
like man how you know
when people scared of you when they walk
in the ring
and he was like you been to penitentiary
you know how when you walk in there you
know who you going [ __ ] ass who's the
[ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] what the
how you know [ __ ] could be
scared of you when they walk in the ring
he said like you've been the
penitentiary
you know who's a [ __ ] when they walk in
right how they look you know who's the
[ __ ] who's gonna get [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like this [ __ ] tyson boy
this [ __ ]
crazy bro was that when you were locked
up was there was there dudes getting
[ __ ] in the ass in there
yeah yeah i walked in on somebody
getting [ __ ]
that's just crazy i didn't know about
the coke can what's the coke can
like if somebody's taking care of their
business in the pen either jerking off
or [ __ ]
yeah they put the coke can on on the end
of the uh
thing by the shop by the shot so you
walk in and you just said i didn't know
about it
[ __ ] well it's crazy because you'll see
like somebody who's straight
and then they end up in jail for life
and then they're
dabbling in the in the whatever tyson
was saying you know what i'm saying
yeah that [ __ ] is crazy so so would you
like if you're in jail and you let's say
you want to rub one out
you got to put the coke can up or is
that just you do something do
you do in your bunk uh nah you got you
got to put the coke can up if you taking
care of [ __ ] in the shower
you know so that put people on game you
know what i'm saying but i didn't know
about that
this was four days me and the pen you
know i wake up early to get my incidents
peeled calls so i gotta wake up before
everybody all the people call people
right they wake up at like four o'clock
so i walk down on a [ __ ] riding
a dick
a grown-ass man
yeah that image is probably never
leaving your head you know
[Music]
like how do you react to that you're
just like i said my bad
walked out did you see the guy later and
be like ah
now i know i know i know about you
like for the next nine years you're like
like or however long you were locked up
with this guy you're like i saw you get
[ __ ] in the ass bro
it's crazy yo it's not but he's a [ __ ]
like [ __ ] don't hide in there like
okay
oh okay okay they know what they're like
they're they're like [ __ ] [ __ ] are
labeled [ __ ] they call about their
name
they call by women names like they don't
piss on side you they have to sit down
and piss
in the penitentiary you know if you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] is not in a
it's not you're a [ __ ] you if your name
clarence is close it's called
clarissa or something you know you're
saying you're a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is crazy hey what what i
thought was uh
you know interesting about about how
kind of how you would
you know your social media have blown up
on um in the last like
16 to 18 months it kind of reminded me
of like when khalid blew up on snapchat
you remember when that happened
yeah remember khaled had that year where
he was just on snapchat on jet skis and
[ __ ]
and like change it really like cal his
bag got so much bigger like how
how much did your social media just
increase like during the pandemic
increase the kind of bags you were
getting bro because you could
that just opens up a whole nother
revenue stream for you i'm sure yeah it
increases heavy you know like
you're 20 000 a drop you know for a
company
so someone wants you to post that [ __ ]
it's 20 bucks you know
if you want you want you want you want
the character to come out
you better go get woo 15 to 20 bands you
know
i do you know i try to do four or five
of them a week have you thought about
getting on twitch
i'm on i'm on cameo now no tw so twitch
is
what you know how t uh t-pain's on
twitch i've been hearing about tweets so
twitch is like you
just live stream most people do gaming
and [ __ ] like you could go on twitch
with your kids
while they're playing video games you
would
murder it on twitch like t-pain like
legit like not to put his business out
there but t-pain's making
astronomical amounts of money on twitch
on twitch like
astronomical amounts like you said
on that on that podcast thing yeah he's
on twitch he'd be [ __ ] screaming you
see the [ __ ] video of him screaming
do something different
that was on his twitch that was on
twitter think about it so t-pain
probably got like i don't know
i think he said he got like eight or
nine thousand subscribers on twitch each
one of them have to pay per month to
subscribe to his
channel oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have twitter
this week bro if you go on twitch
you are going thank you you are going
crazy thank you i'm going to take a [ __ ]
on twitch
you can't take a [ __ ] on twitch oh all
right you just the only thing on twitch
is you i can't do it
you listen just be yourself but don't
do the you can't have [ __ ] on twitch
you can't hear i can't get nobody
twerking
no just go on there i'm telling you i
just talk
your kids are your kids into video games
i've been taking the video games from
listen
snoops on twitch and he like raged quit
on like like
all the yo you would murder it on
twitter i just need to know what i can't
do
you just can't do like any sexual [ __ ]
so imagine if you're just being yourself
on twitch
mine is putting [ __ ] on on it can you
talk about [ __ ] yes
you can talk about all that wild [ __ ] i
can go on twitch and say
i need to know every what's the age
limit of the first
dick that got put in your mouth how old
you was i could put that on twitch i
think so
that's a nice question that's a good
question how you were that's what you
just how old were you when you first
sucked dick
when you first put a dick first into
your mouth how old you
so let me ask you this you say that
determines your character
yeah it helps me it helps me with things
when i does it help you understand
who you are yeah it helps a little
mm-hmm
like if if a girl says 14 you're like
okay you've been doing this a while
right i know what you're with every girl
says 19
right right yeah you're you're probably
a square yeah yeah the draws ain't
probably
all that no the [ __ ] good good good but
you but you ain't nothing just coming
into yeah yeah yeah yeah let me show you
some things
yeah yeah yeah if you saw dick for the
first time when you were 19
yeah come over and i will educate you on
on further things
nah twitch you'll murder it on yo i got
to get that [ __ ] together yeah i'm going
to get on twitch
bro have your kids playing video games
while you're just miked up and playing
with them because i'm assuming you're
probably not very good at the games
i don't know how to play video games it
will be funny
if you just get mic'd up while you're
playing like call of duty and you're not
not good at it but your kids are there
with you
bro you will [ __ ] murder it on twitch
like
that you you'll [ __ ] around and make
more money on twitch than anything in
life
i'm going on twitch this week set up
this yo
check out t-pain [ __ ] do a little setup
at your crib
and it's over for you bro
yeah you and pam what's up yeah but
payne's are having a little comeback
right now you know what i'm saying
he was on facebook with mark zuckerberg
he was i wrote t-pain in this dm
a whole damn paragraph man put me on the
phone with zuck man i need my instagram
did he reply no we ain't done [ __ ] yet
did pain reply though pain ain't reply
to [ __ ] i'm gonna check my instagram
again
he was on facetime with him man pain
though i need my instagram man
and if you're on facetime with somebody
you'll be in contact
yeah put us on the meeting what the [ __ ]
i need to do apologize
maybe yeah well i will
[ __ ] but don't yeah man you playing high
level man
you're gonna see this interview high
level man we gotta get you on t-pain's
podcast
aims up hey that's what we gotta tell
them let's set it up right now
set it up get you back tell them let's
set it up right now t-pain
i'll fly to you right now you want your
podcast go viral
put me in zuck on them it'll go crazy
hey are you you're in atlanta too right
i don't care i know what happens in
atlanta i know what you're paying
for i [ __ ] with you
you got to get zuck on put zuck on right
now man
i need my 10.5 million followers that's
a lot no you don't know how much money
that brings just people
just companies coming to you just you
know without being boosted
your numbers you get paid for your
number so with my character
and those numbers mm-hmm it's over it's
over bro it's over
you don't know what they don't know how
you dent up there in a pocket taking my
instagram that's fair man well listen
boozy
uh you're a legend new album coming out
friday right go talk three
go talk three coming out friday [ __ ] uh
there's gonna be a compilation coming
there's gonna be a twitch page coming
twitch on the way
your twitch is about to go crazy twitch
on the way can i work out on twitch
because i'm yeah
cali got me skinny again i'm gonna work
can i work out on twitter yes
oh yeah i'm gonna put some knee high
shots on
i'm finna show them knees on the beat
yeah i'm finna show that print
i'm finna work out on twitch with the
dick print yeah i'm fine you're gonna
have some great [ __ ] sweaters oh i'm
finna have some tight [ __ ] on on twitch
yo you say callie got you skinny again
what does that even mean
cali bro but callie all we doing is
smoking weed out yeah we not eating good
we're not eating good meals and we back
on time bro
seem like we so tired out here bro yeah
all we're doing is coughing
are you like eating better not in canada
not out here but i just mean just in
general like are you like like how's
your diet like
this i i ain't allowing this
[ __ ] saying i'm eating like a
diabetic
because you're you're diabetic right
yeah yeah i mean like but my health is
better than it has been a year
my health is way better than it has been
in years but it's
it [ __ ] me up because i lost so much
weight when i got shot cause i was in
the bed
so long i lost so much weight when i got
shot but i'm getting it back
i'm getting it back i'm i made it is it
is it pretty hard to deal with being a
diabetic and being on the road so much
uh i guess it's just part of my i
wouldn't it's just part of my life yeah
it's you're used to it at this point i'm
used to it i had it since i was 18 19 so
i'm used to having it's just
when that [ __ ] come down bro it's tough
or if i have a tag bro like if i take
too much medicine and
sleep too long
bro that [ __ ] like painful and you don't
remember that's like when you have a
diabetic seizure like
you don't remember bro everything
you don't remember you just that's crazy
yeah well this would just be worth it
with the money you know the money keep
me on the road
of course i like money man like i used
to like i always tell people
you got eight kids they got all eat you
know what i'm saying i used to rap for
free
so the fact you're getting for money
that's the [ __ ] living
hey living your dream every day you know
what i'm saying well listen i appreciate
you pulling up man
uh oh what's uh talk about talk about
boosie bash
oh boosie badge august 28 little baby
the baby
carla rage is crazy where's this at
baton rouge okay so you're back in baton
rouge
the comedy show the day before and the r
b fills the hands so who's
so who's doing the show it's you little
baby and who the baby
little baby carly ray young blue
she's around her she's a trash dog
moosky she's gonna run away
hey that's your [ __ ] hey we finna kill
it bro like
you got both babies man you know what i
mean and shout out to baby shout out to
liv baby you know
saying they success brother i just thank
him for blessing me bro
you know what i'm saying we're going
we're going to turn up you know what i'm
saying i'm
flying them all in a jet i'm going to
have women with roses pedals
sprinkling it by their feet coming to
america [ __ ] when they jump off the
plane
okay yeah with their body painted with
their body painted yeah
buck naked with their body painted with
all their songs on them little baby
lands
there's butt naked women painted
sprinkling rose petals sprinkling rose
petals on his feet
wow ready and his raw your penis can be
clean your highness
so he's here however he won't do it
what's up with you yeah yeah however he
won't do it like listen sweetheart if
you're going to take the job of painting
your body yeah
yeah yeah yeah you also gotta be willing
to suck a little baby's dick if he wants
it
if he wants it if he wants if he wants
that baby
but if he won't his dick yeah don't wear
dirty air forces or team jordan
if he want his dick so he's going to get
a nice mouth okay okay okay that's a
king man
yeah if he wanted i don't know how baby
get baby probably bring a baby for sure
but if he
but if he won't get took care believe me
believe me he gonna have five have you
ever paid for sex boosie like in life
have you yes yes yes like with
prostitutes
rubbing tugs massage parlors
like yeah i didn't pay for [ __ ] because
i didn't
you know like if like if i'm i'm
throwing a party for
one of my special homes right you know
uh
i'm gonna fly if we throwing it big if
i'm gonna fly all the girls down and you
know
give him a little something too you know
what i'm saying so
but never never a rubbing tug you ever
been to a rubbing tug nah nothing like
that i'm i'm on some [ __ ]
okay okay i'll bring 10 girls down give
them something and all them know what to
do
they know what's up they know what this
money's for they they gonna go
yeah they fully gonna go you know that's
that's but me as just seeing a girl
paying i
did that since 03 me and my boy in
houston we paid a [ __ ] like 300 for the
[ __ ] yeah 300 that's not bad yeah for
two people
oh that's that's that's 150 at pop yeah
so you and your boy paid a prostitute
three hundred dollars and each year no a
stripper
oh stripper well whatever technically
she was a prostitute right
i mean technically if we're getting the
definitions uh you paid the stripper 300
and you guys [ __ ] at the same time
yeah we trained you it was like an
eiffel tower did you guys do the eiffel
tower
nah i trained it you know i i hit him
you know train you know no no but you
know what the eiffel tower is
someone's getting their dick sucked
someone's [ __ ] from behind and then
you guys high five over the [ __ ]
and it is the eiffel tower oh i've been
eiffel tower before i didn't hear the
[ __ ] with the pound
yeah that's eiffel tower yeah okay
that's the new [ __ ] i ain't nobody
i even told the [ __ ] i gotta use it
let's go to paris [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh i got a huge doubt
oh man you just gave me something there
it is
hey for the record i would love to see
you the the you and the baby in like a
buddy cop movie a buddy cop movie
yeah like think of like rush hour
something imagine the baby's so funny
he's got so much personality in his
videos and you together
you guys gotta shoot a video where it's
like it's like i feel like you guys in
like a you know like a buddy cop movie
like but it's called comedy
yeah like a comedy yeah man i'll write
it all right i'm trying to get the baby
in films now i'll write it yeah no i
think it's it's
that'll be crazy but listen i think i
appreciate you pulling up august 20 what
is this
august 28th this friday go talk three go
talk three and if you're
a fan it's worth flying into baton rouge
for this show
yeah but if you're a fan of any artist
that's a crazy lineup
this is crazy if you're a fan of any
artist on the show
you know what i'm saying because my
boozy heads come for sure all across the
world this is like
where some people feel like is that what
you call your fans boozy heads
okay okay cause you know beyonce got the
beehive
boosie heads okay i know these people
they're very very you know they're very
intense humans
i know some of them a lot of them in
jail yes and that's how bootsy you know
people
people don't know how powerful the
bootsy heads are
they're very powerful you know i've been
around some i lived in florida you lived
in florida so i'm aware
no you know listen i remember the first
time you know because i'm from the west
coast
the first time i went to the south and i
heard set it off played in a club where
they actually appreciated it
yeah i was like oh my god it's like some
meek mill dreams and nightmare [ __ ]
like that song in the right city and the
right that [ __ ] is
timeless in florida you know you gotta i
love florida because there's so many
counties
and i'm gonna get money in them counties
forever yeah it's like a country
it's like people don't know it's like
it's south florida it's the middle it's
polk county it's tampa it's orlando when
you get florida bro
palmetto fort myers
tallahassee jacksonville
yeah duval 75 no problem i get seven in
no problem
that's crazy no problem what are you how
much do you pay attention to what's
going on in duval with these with these
young rappers you know there's like
been said that was crazy they're insane
bro like i talked to young and a's i
talked to julio them guys
if if what they doing if
they was in louisiana like
they'd be [ __ ] up it's a lot of it's a
lot of violence man
yeah but you know that's all come with
it though you know have you
have you talked to either of those kids
like either ace or julio because
he's saying i didn't talk to julio but i
never talked to a man about another man
b
that's big [ __ ] yeah that's fair yeah i
don't care who i'm with i never talked
to a man about another man beat [ __ ] if
i ain't gonna kill for that man
that's fair you know that that's big
[ __ ] when [ __ ] go around [ __ ] and
say what's that
with man you said nah [ __ ] that's your
fault it's your business that's your
business
you know i don't talk to never talk to
ace about fulio never talk to julio
about ace who's going to talk to ace
about getting on a record
right talk to fully about getting
getting on the rep who's uh
outside of who's signed to you a young
up and coming rapper or two that you're
that you're really
tapped in with that you really [ __ ] with
just that from a fan's perspective like
someone who you enjoy
what they're doing uh
no man my son's snapping right now they
got another little kid
well your son assigned to you right yeah
so we got another kid named tg cummins
okay our br he next up he like you know
every every couple years somebody coming
from br
for sure so uh he liked he liked the
next like the next up
the [ __ ] snapping tj cummings cg come
on tg come on tg
commas all right oh tg commas yeah okay
okay okay tj
tg commas yeah i want to [ __ ] that up
honey baton rouge coming at me bro you
gonna be on your show one day there it
is bro well listen i appreciate you
pulling up go get the album on friday
get your tickets and fly your ass to
baton rouge and go to boosie bash
august 28th and we got to get the t-pain
mark zuckerberg
yeah uh twitch twitch you got to get on
that twitch
i'm gonna be on twitch i'm letting all
y'all know i'ma be on twitch in a week
how long it takes to get on twitch yeah
it's easy yeah just sign up it's like
signing off
i'm gonna be on twitch in a week there
it is coming soon
lucy yo you're gonna kill it on twitch